[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
las acciones que me gusta debo admitirlo
Y por supuesto también me gusta estar al
lado de mi compañera mar Romero sala mar
bienvenida feliz mañana de jueves vamos
a hablar de un tema que también me gusta
hoy estoy feliz con esta sección no es
que antes no pero pues hoy más grupos
científicos en Japón avanzaron hacia una
vacuna contra el envejecimiento vamos a
desmenuzar esto Sí por supuesto que te
gusta de hecho a todos nos gusta saber
que quizás hay alguna opción para
retrasar algunos de los efectos que va a
tener la edad en nosotros se trata de un
estudio realizado en Japón que se trata
de unas vacunas una vacuna
particularmente que podría atacar unas
células llamadas células zombie en jerga
científica células senecentes que se
acumulan con la edad y que podría estar
en la raíz de varias de las enfermedades
que se relacionan con el envejecimiento
para desmenuzar toda esta información y
resolver nuestras dudas estamos con el
doctor Óscar Franco él es profesor de
epidemiología y de salud pública de la
universidad
doctor muy buenos días y feliz jueves
empecemos por el principio Qué son las
células senecentes Y cómo nos afectan
Sí con el tiempo nuestras células se van
envejeciendo dejan de ser funcionales se
dejan de multiplicar y normalmente esas
células viejas senecentes o células
zombies son eliminadas por nuestro
sistema inmune pero con el tiempo se van
depositando se van acumulando la
eliminación disminuye y pueden producir
una respuesta inflamatoria que puede
llevar a aumentar la probabilidad de
tener enfermedades del corazón o
diabetes por ejemplo Hola doctor muy
buena mañana de jueves le pregunta
entonces o como esta vacuna elimina
estas células del envejecimiento
si lo que encontraron los investigadores
en Japón es que hay unas células
senecentes específicamente en los vasos
sanguíneos y en otros tejidos en el
organismo que tienen una proteína en la
superficie que se puede tratar como un
antígeno entonces desarrollaron una
terapia una vacuna que identifica esta
proteína y que hace que se generen
anticuerpos y las elimine algo así como
las vacunas que tenemos ahora contra el
coronavirus Entonces sería pues una
solución muy muy interesante y muy
importante para poder eliminar estas
células senescentes doctor déjeme
preguntarle esta serie la primera
terapia que existe para eliminar este
tipo de células o hay otras que ya se
están poniendo en práctica y si es así
Qué ventaja podría ofrecer esta posible
vacuna
si en los dos últimos años hemos tenido
muchas terapias cenolíticas en
desarrollo sonoríticas quiere decir que
eliminan estas células viejas o
cenecentes y esas terapias pueden ser un
medicamentos o pueden ser por ejemplo
suplementos nutricionales Y en este caso
lo que se desarrolló fue una vacuna
la ventaja que tiene es que al parecer
Es segura es efectiva y se ha visto que
los efectos que se evaluaron durante
estos estos investigaciones en los
efectos de esta vacuna van a más largo
plazo que las terapias anteriores
Entonces es bastante prometedor ahora
doctor Qué beneficios entonces va a
traer para nosotros eliminar estas
células de nuestro cuerpo Qué
consecuencias por supuesto positivas
podemos ver
lo que se podría esperar es que se
podría reducir o mejorar el proceso del
envejecimiento se producía se
reproduciría un mejoramiento en la salud
vascular y esto podría ayudar a las
personas a poder vivir más tiempo y más
largos sin embargo los estudios que se
han hecho hasta ahora son estudios en
ratones y tenemos que esperar a ver qué
pasa de hecho Precisamente en ese
sentido quería preguntarle No qué tiene
que suceder para que estos estudios que
por ahora todavía son en ratones avancen
y se conviertan un candidato vacunal
para los humanos
si ahora mismo es una prueba de concepto
un concepto que es bastante promisorio
que es bastante positivo que Ojalá
funcione que es lo que Todos queremos
sin embargo hemos visto como de la fase
preclínica la fase clínica cuando ya la
evaluamos en humanos muchas veces las
cosas que se encuentran en roedores Son
animales no aplican a los seres humanos
ahora mismo hay que continuar evaluando
si se pueden identificar estas proteínas
ver qué tan seguros son las vacunas que
tan efectivas son y tal vez pasar ya a
la evaluación en humanos pero todavía
estamos a años de poder tener un
producto en el mercado sin embargo Pues
es lo que la esperanza que tenemos de
poder reducir el proceso de
envejecimiento de ayudar a la gente a
vivir más tiempo y de manera saludable
es decir que todavía si vamos entonces a
envejecer más rápido antes de esa vacuna
doctor y mar muchísimas gracias entonces
por esta sección de salud del día de hoy
nos vemos más adelante y pasamos ahora a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día